pearson airport in southern ukraine has
been attacked
the strategic port city has been held by
russian troops since the early days of
the war
the airport has been turned into a
russian military base
but ukrainian forces are fighting back
dozens of russian vehicles and aircraft
have been destroyed
this zed marking has been seen on
russian vehicles throughout the conflict
the person filming is here they appear
to be a member of the russian military
russia has based some helicopters here
since it advanced into the area
in this ukrainian attack open source
analysts suggest 10 helicopters may have
been destroyed
we see an inventory fighting vehicle
pass by
they can be heard talking about moving
some of the vehicles away
is the russian vehicle manufacturer that
made these trucks they could be used to
transport supplies fuel and personnel
a group of three soldiers filmed this
clip from the other side of the airport
russian soldiers have been wearing white
armbands for identification
they're coming from a temporary camp
pictured by satellite images
before the conflict this was an
international airport a destination in
ryanair's schedule the same place now
looks like this
foreign